it's gonna die anyway I'm sorry baby
let's get I killed myself No oh my god
Walking Dead episode 3 it's out the
episode that wasn't supposed to come out
the company just goes bankrupt out of
nowhere and everyone is freaking out how
did this happen
oh my god but here we are anyway they
managed to do it somehow I don't know
how this is gonna be hey this might be a
total [ __ ] fest it just hit me I'm very
thankful to the people that pull through
to get this done for the fans it seems
like that's the case here you know the
company has gone bankrupt anyway so
really big ups to everyone that worked
to get this done episode 4 as we can see
is gonna come out as well in march 26 so
we're gonna get the conclusion of
clementines destiny and there's no
reason for me to keep waiting start oh
yeah they have it there another poor
game design choice just kidding there's
no reason for me to walking dead while
searching for a place to call home
AJ and I found in old boardings I got G
fuel inside of here deep in the forest
their leader was a guy named Marlin and
AJ and pulled the trigger
yeah thanks AJ thank you very much that
he'd have to atone for it the other kids
agreed they voted to kick us out I
thought we'd never return then five
minutes passed and we were back hacked
by Abel Harlan had given the twins to he
was with someone I thought I'd never see
again
Obama Lilly okay
we were almost eaten by walkers when
suddenly one of them spoke to me they
can toss James an ounce whisper who
didn't believe in killing walkers
he helped me treat AJ but without real
medicine he wouldn't make it the kids
didn't turn away sad side of AJ and let
us back inside after I told them how we
could defend the school against the
Raiders they were willing to let us stay
at least until the fight I decided to
help violent happen there I looked at
the stars together violet is a
girlfriend those are rare submit junkie
Raiders for Gabby
they busted open our gates but the kids
stayed hidden as planned until 10:00 ran
out of cover hoping for a chance to
learn about his missing sisters the bomb
went off and attempting to save 10 Mitch
threw himself at Lily and got a knife to
the throat good damn me a second to
decide
I fired and saved Lewis
you're welcome Louis they got away with
three of our friends we had no oh but we
knew someone who did this will be
interesting to say the least
oh man Jesus Christ I figured they would
have already started on the episode
three when they went bankrupt and
everyone had to leave but I don't know
really like anything about that already
these games are kind of wonky already
like there's some pretty funny bugs that
appear here and there some really
curious just how this will affect the
quality I mean that looks pretty good
thanks for that that looks I mean I'll
take it
my god he's this frozen solid
I guess his rigor mortis you could blame
it on it sorry I need to stop looking at
everything through this lens he was
always nice to me because you're a [ __ ]
let's go for a revenge I promise you
Willy
the people who did this we're going to
hit them back they're gonna regret ever
coming near us there why not if Mitch
were here he wouldn't cry he'd find a
way to get our friends back that's right
Lily's brains out with a rock
can't waves tied up in the basement he
passed out from the pain
Thanks AJ wanted to stay down there and
keep an eye on him
hey buddy it's time for us to bury Mitch
and say our goodbyes the reason he's
dead
yeah it's true we had a plan B knives
even investor oh oh god no even if it's
true you can't lash out oh god you're
ugly each other you think it's true
oh so I hold that came out wrong talk to
Abel see if you can't find out where
Lily took vaio Mar and a sin well I'm
already making all the wrong choices
this will be great I can't wait to read
the comments I just couldn't
maybe you'll get more out of him than I
did
okay let's go down and check on him
great oh I'm gone what's my attention
Edgar please I'm playing video games all
right fine oh never mind
interrogate Abel okay
all right mr. dog I've got some
questions for you where are the money
huh where did you put the money mr.
ables
huh look at the bloodstains all right
detective
Clementine must be great fruit all right
spill it out Rosie
oh she teleported Oh Rosie doesn't trust
you yet Rosie what do you want to be
like play a video game so we can bond a
little bit
oh my god he's actually crazy
I don't like those eyes that tape does
not look tight enough ready shoot him in
a dick yet God everyone is so ugly ain't
no way to wake an old man up from his
afternoon nap I was having a nice dream
too about a girl I used to know from
before she also had me tied up but I
wasn't a prisoner if you get my meaning
oh hell yes prophase the new water okay
actually he actually gave you ten how
about that you got a good man or squirt
I think I made the wrong choice there I
think I'm gonna get the bad ending now
you've had your water no it's time to
talk it's the first time interrogating
someone isn't it you let me dictate the
agenda makes me think you're weak dog
didn't like that Hey
I just want to know where Lily took my
people it doesn't matter as soon as she
gets there she's gonna turn around and
come right back for me you had to give
me the five-star treatment if I'm
smiling when she gets here you might be
able to trade me for a little mercy we
underestimated you little shits but
Lily won't make the same mistake twice I
mean I think he's right we'll do it
again
hoedown a surprise didn't record you'd
know how to scrap now we know just tell
us where they took off friends so we can
get him back then what hey Lily we'll
never give them up only reason we came
here was for more manpower losing
Jonathan and me three sprouts can barely
hold a gun
even if L me like me can do it well
maybe the Whisperer will help us
actually tease or Diddy apples you don't
know what it's like out there it's a
bloodbath one community against another
from Richmond to the coast back in the
Delta were at war with some really sick
[ __ ] who made me look like the Virgin
Mary we need people to fight it soldiers
who do what we say point the guns the
way we tell them to you little church is
supposed to be easy pickins kidnapping
you can't just not take it whatever name
you want I call it survival what kind of
place is this Delta if they use forced
labor to defend it you think we like
doing raids like this yes home is under
threat it's a good home built to last
I do a lot to protect it maybe you can
understand that and I do a lot to get my
friends back so stop wasting my time
okay front pocket I answered all your
questions you didn't search him already
idiot read it whatsoever parted the
possible meme incoming footed and never
mind the cud among the beasts that shall
you eat what the [ __ ] is this code no
it's [ __ ] a little bit ass
Clementine please don't swear I was
hoping it'd be some timely moralistic
[ __ ] about turning the other cheek
well c'mon
that thing ain't gonna light itself
clear my mind he's actually oh my god
where did I go oh my god member stuff
burn Headley went to hell get I [ __ ] it
I don't really care here here - hit it
hit it man oh my god what was in the
joint dude
he's gonna die isn't he I love that you
try and do something nice for someone
and they literally cough up blood patch
him up passion buck man patch him up hmm
I don't think so we can cover up that
bald spot don't worry about it
something must've burst inside of me no
medicine can fix this oh I know things
dead like this everything y'all got out
of hand now look at me now a [ __ ]
best bully turn No
yeah I think that's it yes my whole life
everything I ever got I got with my own
two hands and my will for my body the
dirt on me the day control I'll tell you
where to find Lily just promise you
won't let me turn Hey okay we got
yourself a deal they're listed poor man
yeah all right you have my word which
means a lot in this universe I'll put
you out of your misery you have my word
okay we have a boat we're dogs few miles
west of here
your friends are on the boat oh look
they're on the boat excellent where
where where
okay well are you turning already all
right all right
shoot him in the decade come on
not that I wanna let me keep my face I
wouldn't worry about your faces I was
you buddy if I were you okay I want you
to see this but the [ __ ] Psychopaths
don't need to watch this I want to well
he's already a psychopath great you'll
make a great youtuber all right so let's
just aim for like this area okay let's
see oh I did it anyway yeah yo are you
just just kind of throat or something oh
how is that better
how is that better they getting shot in
the face at least he can't hurt anyone
anymore
hey shut up AJ that was not mercy that
was disgusting
come on we have a boat to find why would
you ill AJ stop me you're freaking me
out AJ stop it stop it AJ stop it AJ AJ
Skybound oh I'm not skip this okay last
time I got a copyright strike because
this goddamn menu alright I'm just gonna
sit through it
once we find the boat we'll look for a
way to sneak on board yeah 10 doesn't
[ __ ] it up this time a 10 can do it if
he wants yeah thanks aging Mitch die
because say one more thing about Tim I
dare you guys oh there it is
so who did they kidnap again they kidnap
the girl and was there anyone else okay
they got a bow
Fitzgerald you see anything the beach a
boat and wood street thanks AJ I'm
proving again that you sub Sarah I thank
you Jesus Christ let's spread out focus
on those areas your head's low I like
how when oh my god I forgetting
everyone's names I like what with
Clementine you know the main thing that
she was taught by the character in the
first game was to cut her hair so that
she wouldn't get hurt and now she takes
care of another person and he has a
goddamn afro they're probably the
easiest thing you could grab everybody
horses I'm sorry thing I might even one
one seeing this okay so they have like
torches oh I see it torches no I think
it's a stick with fire on it the easy
fire good joke setting hay on fire would
get their attention
scared that never consent the horse is
on fire and you cement bombs yeah I like
that you think your horse is free we
could slow down anyone trying to chase
us
I'm sorry but if there were zombies out
and about how can you just leave horses
around unprotected oh that's right I'm
right about everything
no way pretty sure I would have
remembered an old-timey riverboat from
where I'm sitting
looks like that pier is the only way
inside well let's see what else is down
there okay so we have like a box here
the pier has plenty of cover on it if
we're careful we can sneak in undetected
hmm I like that idea I can see an
entrance yeah there's one of the other
end of the boat - there's a small
opening at the top of those closed
doorways AJ and I know how to deal with
those and so do I buy a bomb sex joke
obvious place to keep prisoners don't
boats have brigs boat jails
maybe but where now that I I I don't
know there are a few on deck couple
others on the pier could be more inside
wait I see pilot oh this is really it
we found them incredible job guys
alright what else do I need to look at
here the path there's no good cover
leading up to the boat we can do better
hell of a distraction our snake snake
tactic six crawl I'm really good
zombies someone's shooting really well I
hope she looks so funny when they
binoculars now we just need what a dozen
walkers how hard could that be
evening he's not as hard as you'd think
okay so now we go right all right do I
talk to you talk to Willy really what
are you even looking at like the boat is
over here such a ball full of bags man
anything useful not failing material
furniture probably stuff from the train
station okay well you can't talk
properly anywhere didn't quite a bit of
it should have that stuff I like I like
your thinking Willy I changed my mind
dude they have dorchester more torches
towards oh my god this is changing its
fire oh yeah I said it before they did
it oh you know scraps with supplies I
could cut those loose and just write
them down River easy oh my god
sorry really but you are like SuperDuper
smart we should get out of here before
they spot us we can talk to the plan
once we're somewhere safe okay
little disappointed that that I never
use the snake tactics but I'll live look
at that one strong go like grass
covering the streets all right what's
the plan
they've got guards posted on the pier
and the boat there's no way we can take
them all at once our only hope is to
distract them while we sneak make a fire
release the horses that work we could
burn the supplies or the hay they keep
for the horses whatever we don't burn we
should take Ruby you'd love to have the
horses but I'd rather steal those
supplies I could build traps I would
rather use that I would rather you say
we'll take the horses and ignore can and
this is des she's like a horse whisperer
the fire will lure the Raiders away from
the boat and we can sneak across the
pier if anyone sees us shoot no no up
Willy you remember that guy I told you
about James
I have a question isn't in walkers to
save us from lily and abel maybe we
could convince him to do it again if we
either he did they're on to the beach we
can blend in without being seen
well hell yeah let's find out how much
he charges for his services what about
after we get everyone home I mean they
just got my tack us again what then hide
quick Oh killer killer oh I got to click
finally something Oh why my thumb is
like on the
what is happening there all right has to
be you all stay here I'll see if they
know anything that could help us
ha got you [ __ ] ha ha you're mine now
and man how many Raiders are there how
many are there how many who shut up I'm
not [ __ ] around answer the clear
eight you lie to me one more time and
your throat is gonna get hey Minnie oh
she's one of the past captives yeah
after the attack I wasn't sure I mean I
heard they burned half your school down
who survived Ruby
Mitch Brodie Ruby and ten minute
interesting
and Brody uh she died
Dan's boots holding up okay his boots
were so hot they're more holes than
rubber had that taped him up the last
time I saw him but that was a while ago
his boots are fine too your Clementine a
girl who took over after Arlen died
[Music]
I thought everyone would want to lean on
their own
to be put in charge it just sort of
happened
wishy-washy [ __ ] you see everyone
back home or just me
excuse me
people figured he could talk Merlin into
handing everyone over like he and Lily
did like they did before you ruined the
whole plan oh my gosh what just happen
Marlin traded through it Sophie like it
was nothing
yeah and we all survived it your point
actually never made them fight the way
you did he wouldn't have gotten people
killed
that is some grade-a [ __ ] clémence
saved us
[Music]
Brody that's right
Minerva where's Sophie
she died protecting the Delta a hero
[Music]
my hero God you know Shh [ __ ] okay
everyone get down okay we're good finish
up and head back I want to be in before
dark
sorry I was just staring at my backs yes
ma'am
our boat leaves for the Delta in two
days then it'll be a couple of weeks
before we can come back for the rest of
you when we do don't fight the only one
ever ever save your people is to let us
take them I am serious don't fight this
the last time your people attacked us
you lost you men you lose more if you
come back will she though will is she
bout cool look at her go are you okay it
doesn't change anything
we still have to get onto that boat
alright let's get to it guys come on all
right enough talk about feelings he well
should head home start getting things
ready get everyone caught up on the plan
that's right except 10 I warned you both
of you
damn AJ will go find James he has no
chill
how old is AJ like three uh he's
absolutely crazy just do that okay AJ
I'm sorry but like you need to cool it
how many walkers do you think James will
help us get fifteen hundred thousand ow
gunshot wound it feels like someone
pinched me from inside doesn't sound
that bad just a second
when I keep thinking when Willie said
all that stuff about ten before I got so
mad yes he was being mean ten wasn't
even there to defend himself that's
correct
I heard him I know I shouldn't but I
just can't stop thinking about it
well that's cuz you're a big old poopy
head punches head you're a big ol [ __ ]
you lucky boobies not breathing kicking
rocks well you got anger issues I just
let the anger pass I know it's hard AJ
but thoughts like that they go away
you just have to give it time waiting's
hard I'm just thinking too much don't do
your head might explode I think I think
I'm mad at tend to running out of cover
when Lilly attacked the school was
really stupid
but he just doesn't know stuff like we
do and then Willie started yelling at
him instead of helping him learn why
don't the other kids know all the stuff
we know and there's a plan you have to
follow it and when you yell at someone
it just makes them not listen ok we'll
teach them they're smart someone just
has to show them what to do yeah I want
him to know how to be safe we can show
them how to be smart like us it's weird
that people are talking about us it is
Erikson's boarding school for troubled
youth troubled youth trouble like bad
yeah like there's bad things y-yeah okay
um sometimes they do them because bad
things happened to them I knew a doctor
once back when you were just a baby
he called it trauma you have some too
you know the thing where people can't
walk up behind you I don't like my
trauma I want to get it off of me how do
I get rid of I don't even like the way
the words five a somersault
consecutively and then it should do that
trick I'll [ __ ] sorry it's just not a
way to get rid of it you'll get help
okay beefs up I still like them
has anything happened to AJ that makes
him so about people coming up and I
guess in zombies but actually I think
he's my first real friend oh yeah I
thought I was your first real friend
oh yeah but you don't count your old Oh
No Oh fine
he's my second folks real friend Dan
Clementine just got savaged by a three
year old
you think the guys near is that it
[Music]
vast orbited Ariela aha okay I am in
lumen lashavia hello one
I love while Aidan on dad I lay over
there on our fine
I don't see James just monsters okay
racist James you hurt hey hey hey
the Raiders do this new fort night dance
look like they had people from your
school why are you here those people you
saw we're going to save them and you're
gonna help us for no reason to do that
we need your help moving some walkers I
could maybe help but my mask is still in
the camp inside my bag I can't pass
through a herd without it
[Music]
okay let's go get it please I just just
ask that you don't kill them
the walkers if you distract him so I
over and find my mask destroy all of
them please I'll try
okay use e to stun them okay so we're
just gonna stun them oh my god what
happened there all right shift to run
I can't run here great
[Music]
the I just have to survive for a second
time and dead now I'm not
yeah nice nice did you buy your mask the
horses must have their the horses are
wearing the mask hey thanks for helping
out AJ more like JJ get it cuz he's
I'm clicking so hard oh wow and now II
there it is it did it yeah look where
he's pushing II nay
get those knees Clementine
you did not do that oh hell no and now
kiss hey Jay are you okay yeah no lights
except mine I know it would have been
easier to kill them
your kind I appreciate it really I'm not
that yeah
bad man oh god it's so horrifying thank
you for helping me get this back now how
will Walker save your friends they're
being held captive on a boat not too far
from here we can't sneak on board
without cover
not without the Raiders gunning us down
you want to use walkers to hide to sneak
on board their ship that's insane
it's our only chance
I have something I need you to see oh
you can understand what you're asking
okay James if they're just gonna die oh
yeah is he gonna show us something
actually interesting and revealing about
the zombies maybe that's something that
we don't know about maybe they actually
have some behavioural that is actually
devil where that would be I think it's
safe
like how he makes it so easy you just
throw a rock and get rid of the zombie
further we've been fighting them off
like hopelessly for years and then it's
gonna throw rock okay that's pretty cool
AJ now it's not the time to take a [ __ ]
Jesus Christ just someone just take a
[ __ ] without flushing their toilet well
it was one of yours sorry my people and
my former people they had a practice
cool they can talk without moving at all
did collecting
my people okay we have an army this is
epic
they use them as a weapon I do this to
protect them I know it sounds strange
but that's why I brought you here to see
them as I do as people yes I was it nice
- if there were people how was it nice
keep them like that actly but something
in between part of us is still in there
deep down yeah it's something for sorry
anymore
we turn not dead not alive god I hope
that's not true
that sounds like hell to you maybe I
think it seems peaceful so do you really
think there's people inside of monsters
somewhere yes so what about us this way
as someone you cared about turned not
Klum's friend we she shot him before he
did oh she doesn't like to talk about it
sorry maybe this wasn't the best way to
explain didn't mean to bring up
difficult memories
I lived among walkers for years I still
do in a way when they're alone they're
harmless innocent if you want my help I
need you to try and walk with them walk
with manually believe they're just
monsters okay I'm down they are just
monsters they're not people or friends
Klim oh my gosh sure what just happened
she'll be safe I really need to set up
my lights
this isn't smart it's too dangerous
yeah I want to do is sound smaller I'll
need you to save me okay can you do that
I yes I'll always protect you I know you
will
[Applause]
yeah the sound put it up put it up never
go alone I'm not leaving you
I'll be right back check the windows I
will don't let fear take over I will I
promise all right AJ the mask will
disguise your scent but be gentle and be
quiet touch the wind chime you'll see
the hell is this guy Allen this is some
hippie made baby my job buddy back oh
I'm gonna touch the wind chime okay this
time cool first-person action happening
guys hey guys what's up whether
somebody's do in their spare time
zombie rave let's all do the floss for
tonight dance in unison I think that
will be really epic imagine how many
views on YouTube we could get or maybe
we could just do the dab oh sorry
they're like a total [ __ ] they're
like pushing each other loss like a box
loss what about long
like in Laos come on man dude were so
close to the Vince
did we are so
yeah she looks up funny
[Music]
come on doctor win time oh my god you
taught the went and a mirror derailleur
of the god oh my god
there went I'm goddamn that is not a
good look for you Clementine I'm sorry
oh my god what it dad to win time oh my
god I love it
Robert oh man
don't winter
where
[Music]
the wind
whoa hey there kiddo that was cute
gonna have to take a lunch break hey
we're back everybody is gaming time okay
no what are you doing do you still think
they're just monsters yes yes I do
you've seen them at peace uh yeah I do
there's still just one stirs dangerous
things Jesus kill us that's what I
thought you would say it's what sorry
Brett said to once okay
what changed never killed a welcome
before and I have many have you ever
killed a person again I swear to God to
you I will kill a person and that person
is you but that was a long time ago I've
killed someone before - AJ AJ you've
killed someone you know I'm not afraid
to kill again what's up dude well that's
good never Tomi in videos anymore
you never tell me about her Oh H me
where are you going to help us save our
friends who shot guy can I wear masks
can I eat the mask but I can't so many
walkers would die yeah don't mind our
diet I would read AI would cause I'm
sorry Clementine I can't have more blood
on my hands job they don't have a bright
one with the different eyes what was his
name
his name what do you how about the woman
in the back near the wind chimes what's
her name I don't know a sim Omar violent
those are the names of my friends the
ones who were stolen by the Raiders I'll
never forget that
who is your shower boy I said Jack ah
George I asked you why are you such a
poche I may be stubborn but I'm not
heartless those Raiders are cruel yeah
we convinced him yay
hope we're a P and even if your friends
think like you no one deserves that
hey youtube do you want to see my secret
I have extra nipple let's take a look at
theirs then through the forest to the
show oh you're right there though it's
my extra leg hey don't show those not
your dime you ready oh don't do this
yeah looks like your testicle pears a
sorry screw
Shh don't be such a pushing what are you
a testicle
go forth my Cheerwine
[Music]
okay it's it's jailing time
gaming with Edgar and Felix I don't have
to press any buttons anyway so it's not
like it makes a difference also now
drinking G fuel what you can't da what a
giant can I have Chum I mean he's tough
not like you though he doesn't kill
monsters but no he's not scared of them
either he's cool
hey Clem Willie told me the plan how
things go with that guy James he agreed
to help us if somebody told me we were
gonna sneak onto a boat and I heard of
Walker's I'd call them crazy what are
you doing with those yeah good question
I wanted to throw one last hootenanny
before the hootenanny might swear huh it
sounds like a swear yeah what's a
hootenanny
hell is a hootenanny and what the [ __ ]
is that hootenanny same party all right
I want to go out ass oh my god they're
right turn now from shakier don't need
something to lift their spirits right
about now
this could be her last chance hmm I
wouldn't make some tea for everyone
could I borrow your little heater thing
what can I do
we need to pretty up the old music room
could you make us something colorful to
hang up okay I'll be an artist
all right look at this what is this
Edgar what do you call this make the
deck decoration a decoration for the
party okay hey I'll get the heater oh
look I get to do stuff okay so place the
collectibles before leaving your mess it
up or okay so coffee
yeah Just Dial fit right in my pocket
stop quite a diet in the game pill it's
not quote the developer works very hard
on there
oh I'm pouring help me I'm actually you
this is a normal boy hey you're getting
better at this
soon you'll be as good an artist as 10 I
don't know he's really good
Oh something wrong hey I was just
thinking about stuff while I was drawing
there are three kind of highs Clem hmm
oh yeah there are live people eyes we
got those then there's monsters eyes
usually look like dirty water
other times monsters eyes aren't even
wet and then there are live people eyes
right did you kill him
like you did to Abel Jesus his his eyes
look like you blew a candle out he was a
bad guy I know I shouldn't feel like
this I hated him too I think there's
something wrong with me you know what AJ
everything you're feeling super see it
makes you a good person am I good
I want to be better clean what people
know I'm good just by my face and you're
the best okay
I'm getting real smart I don't think so
is that right yes because I'm always
thinking all the time hey what are you
thinking about right now
you getting big turning into a monster
oh thanks oh yeah the older I get the
more I see it I don't know why what
happened breakfast tea anyone can I eat
you doesn't matter if you're inside or
outside or how careful you are well
first it would suck like big time and
then I'd have to nom-nom-nom-nom or
shadowing everyone it's gonna happen or
what we talked about what you're
supposed to do if it happens listen to
me if I get bit you'll
run away as fast as no no I'm not gonna
do that
hey Jay you prize don't care I'm not
leaving you if you get bit I don't want
you to bite me too
okay what that was a joke please don't
be mad I can't live with you not with me
Clem I know we've talked about it so
much but don't make me okay if that's
how you want it when I turn into a
monster I will bite you really yeah like
so hard
be serious Clem you can't break promises
AJ I know accept people do all the time
in this video game Jesus Christ James
said guess not
that wood could be around more monsters
like on the inside if you got bit and
then bit me then maybe we'd still be
together it would just be a different
together we might even be okay do you
think so let's say James might be right
that monsters have part of the person
they were still inside them the thing is
no one can prove that and if we can't
prove it we're not going to risk our
lives over it
can I go patrol for a bit before the
party sure go ahead
be careful I don't think he's case you'd
have a gun I'm sorry Hey shoot up I'm
going on Patrol so patrolling is a thing
mm-hmm patrolling the thing
my god sorry I was wondering well I
can't help but thinking what what do you
want you shot that Raider who grabbed me
but you saw them take violet too which
means you could have saved violet and
not me why why would you pick me I mean
I wouldn't have picked me hell I don't
know anyone who would have picked me I
honestly didn't have time to think
really have time to think I just made a
split-second decision what do you want
me to say I love you and I wanna be with
you coz I don't I know I'm always
teasing her trying to get her to do that
one eye roll she does you know the one
where it's like you're such a dumbass
she has to do a full body I roll you
know I do it because when I actually do
manage to make her laugh it's worth it
if I needed her she'd be there meat
cleaver in hand ready to chop someone in
half if it meant protected me
hey we're going to get them back Louis
[Music]
yeah damn right we will hey Clem
oh now I messed it up
I wasn't ready my hand was in my own
head guy she's gonna get it in their
face oh I got it Oh God
Wow where did you find a beach ball it
was in some garbage but on one of the
girls I had to blow it up and that was
pretty gross but look it works start
heading back to the admin building it's
cool right yeah yeah toss it in his face
again Oh
I love you Clem I love you back kiddo
okay we better get ready to go sounds
like such a nice moment okay
you
the dice do the thing when you were kids
you your shitty drawings you would sell
them to your parents hey remember what a
dick move that was right on that banner
if we're gonna die we should have some
fun first well I could put prices on
them and stuff like that me my sister
over there god no I would actually
attend this thing oh I get to choose
candle color oh yeah yeah ha was she
with you bros red purple or green
I can't green I can't do it I'm just
gonna have to pick triple dot and
something to complement that maybe I
just leave it to me then but don't be
surprised if it's green ah green that is
check this out when you turn that crank
there it plays me pulled out the old
Headmaster's gramophones they could play
some records deaf matches the selection
but it should do wouldn't happen to have
any good jazz records would you oh yeah
I wish in a big country teacher it was a
big fan pretty cool guy up until he
ditched us all what's jazz sound like
it'll make sense when you hear it do you
like jazz AJ huh are we using the banner
for some kind of party theme hmm not
exactly it's meant to be more
motivational I keep it short though it's
not as much room as you think hey Jay Oh
ed you pick with something really I have
an idea it'll be telling people that put
stuff on signs isn't really my strong
sign okay we'll have 10 break out his
paintbrush and write it out this place
is gonna look great I think with a green
it's really gonna pop but that's just my
opinion
dude is that a crank in the middle of
the one ask him for you
he's up in Marlins office said he had a
surprise for the party but he wanted to
show it to you first
you crank that wall hey Clem check it
out I found a bunch of books on ships
okay here's some awesome stuff about
fires at sea and explosions and stuff
the key is the boiler wait what are you
talking about I can make the boiler
explode yeah about how to stop those
[ __ ] coming back to the school after
we've rescued the others and from
hurting anyone else ever again
we're gonna blow up the boat I like this
guy this guy is on my my
I know this feels right you know from
Mitch is it me or is there a bit of a
bomb obsession at this school well it's
not you they're totally is but for good
reason the tricky bit is timing
explosions so that it happens after you
get off the boat oh yeah you're gonna
blow at the boat this'll work
we'll be okay now I'm into it and um
Clem I'm sorry for before about how I
treated 10 all right buddy gets so angry
I know it's not his fault I your
apologize just cuz you had a good idea
for once in your life
[Music]
oh yeah write it down
oh that is ugly
[Music]
I'm frosting
Wow
this looks great Ruby gonna done it
without you but just wait to see what
else I've got planned go ahead and
mingle I'll let you know when it's time
I guess I'll mingle I see you two are
working together yeah Willy asked me to
help with his special project okay
that's nice is it ready good to go Clem
it'll work let's blow out the freaking
bomb it's gonna be just like I was
thinking maybe we should name it
something cool yeah I mean I think it
deserves a name yeah we absolutely have
to name it I thought you make fun of me
but hell yeah let's name is [ __ ] Willy
Junior
Ruby's revenge Ruby's revenge basket
Ruby yeah hell yeah
Ruby's revenge oh no wait damn right I
don't like that actually never mind
well it's better than my idea which I'm
not gonna say out loud so okay
Clementine these here are our official
Erickson psych evaluations and
probationary reports okay I don't get it
well these explain why all of us got
sent to this school in the first place
and how we got stuck here for as long as
we did so what's the game I figured if
we're all going on this crazy mission
together might as well know who we
really are so I'll read some of what the
are they not found this before he's
gonna finally have to guess which one of
us fits the bill I'll make sure it's
someone you've actually met this will be
the first one while otherwise a
remarkable student Blanc continues to be
plagued by fits of anger uncontrollable
cursing and repeated physical
altercations with the senior
and that's all of you tent I don't know
Marlon well not to speak ill of the dead
but that sounds exactly like Marlon oh
my god Marlon are you there
guess it does but know wasn't him it was
Ruby guilty as charged
our sweet Ruby here was kind of a
nightmare
when she first showed up Lulu she once
she's the home egg teacher around the
yard with a barbecue fork this big no
way
don't worry that was a long time ago I
mean I can totally see it the first time
I met Ruby she was all that little
[ __ ] I said I was sorry you guys
wouldn't know why I gots it here no okay
guys gonna end that episode there hope
you guys enjoyed watching smash like if
you enjoyed and also remember to
subscribe okay fine Willy I speak for
all of us when I say nobody has ever
ever wanted to know that what does that
mean have we ever shake his hand and we
ever touched him anyway maybe we should
change up the music like all kind of
different music I think there's a lot of
them country roads country on take me
home to to pray Abbey rug West Virginia
pretty nice
[Music]
I didn't realize how many of us we lost
remember that Justin guy and the Rissa
and Jasper that one girl with colored
braces and Joey Maddy
Lamarr Erin she had the braces Alex do
we train Stephanie no this seems like a
bad Eva died
34 Jesus
well you know you live some you lose
some
you know even what are you gonna do cry
about it whose is it
violets well the point of the game was
that you weren't gonna tell me
i I I could tell you guys my story
instead what got me sent here I mean
chronic masturbation if you want it's
not great
I was saying geez tell me so my family
was stupid rich parents gave me
everything I wanted when I wanted it
except for one thing singing lessons God
I begged my dad told him I wanted to be
a real musician but all he said was you
get to be happy or you get to be rich
can't be both I know now that he was
just trying to teach me a dumb dad
lesson but I hated him for that what was
it that lesson so I decided I teach him
a lesson I thought I'll break up my
parents marriage that hurt real bad
right okay what I broke into my dad's
credit card accounts and made all these
purchases in his name did this for over
a year this is how rich we were he never
noticed he was spending a fortune on a
mistress that I'd made up for him oh but
I made sure my mom did Oh
sent her all the receipts for the hotel
rooms the jewelry all of it
damn he's slick they had a fight all
night long he denied it she wouldn't
have it I sat in the corner and cried to
help it feel more real when their
divorce was final
I told them the truth Oh I said you get
to be happy or you get to be rich you
don't get to be both what you know those
who would have been happily married
forever but then I had to go be a
vindictive [ __ ]
I mean yeah oh my god I came here the
week after I mean at least you don't
have chronic masturbation as your option
that's [ __ ] up okay so that's pretty
[ __ ] up I'm in complete and total
agreement they said we were bad people
Glenn they went wrong
stea went wrong none of us deserve to be
ditched out here in the middle of the
forest by the people that were supposed
to make us better sorry this was
supposed to be fun yeah I guess I'm not
really a game person what kind of person
are you vile and eat yourself up you
said it yourself son needs to know who
she's leading into battle hey I've got
an idea just roll in mini would sing us
don't be afraid when all of us used to
get scared of course I remember yeah I
helped compose it with her could you
maybe play it for us if I was here she
could sing the words but yeah yeah I'd
love to ten
this is for you many actually like the
green
[Music]
I'll ask someone that doesn't look good
in green I'm sorry but
I should have picked something else
why
he's thinking too hard again for AJ
you
[Music]
now let's blow out the boat who's with
me
blow at the boat blow up the boat blow
out the boat come on everybody let's
blow out the boat blow up the boat
chuja chuja yeah
oh no the feels
don't do me like this Lee hey sweet pea
my god she was so precious damn he looks
good
damn the tray Daniel always picked the
tray I'm not sure maybe because this is
where it all started
are you taught me to shoot and to cut my
hair to be ready for what was coming
oh you were a quick study
so what's on your mind this time
I'm worried Li I've got a lot of people
depending on me and I don't know if what
I'm doing is right oh I know that
feeling
you know I was making it all up as I
went along right yeah
couldn't let on of course I don't think
you were fooling anyone
hey don't feel bad monsters took over
the world and you got stuck taking care
of an eight year old girl what were you
supposed to do I guess I let her chill a
little hard
you want to tell me about what you're up
against
I'm with a new group now and I've been
in so many and they always fall apart I
really like this one it's different
it almost feels like home
that's a good thing Todd being alone out
there but we're in trouble some bad
people captured my friends and getting
them back might get the rest of us
killed
I'm not worried
what
whatever trouble you're in you get out
of it you get your friends out of it you
don't know that I know you're a survivor
but Clementine I know was gonna fix it
I really believe that you're right I
just needed to hear you say I'm going to
get my friends out of this every one of
them alive that's right
imagine how violet will feel when she
finds out you came to rescue her you'll
have given her hope again I'll sweetie
you know you always get like this before
something big remember how scared you
were before you charged into that mess
of maccarrol branch you survived that
didn't you that was different I was
alone I know it's harder when you have
something to lose but having people you
care about that's a good thing they're
fighting beside you because of you
come see me again when you've gotten
them out okay out and safe
sound good and hopefully we can talk
about happier things we I miss you so
much
I wish you knew here yeah I miss you too
Clementine but we'll have to make do
with pretending Oh
Thank You Lee talking to you always
makes me feel a little bit better
jumps up the train let's ask how's the
board
he's goodly you'd like him dad you teach
him to shoot yet yeah I did it was
terrible idea
yeah exactly yeah ha ha I guess the
world got pretty hard since I left it
kid growing up in it he'd be hard to
you're in my shoes now raising a kid I
think you got a handle on it alright
yeah thank you everybody willing to give
him a childhood but knowing what it
takes to survive now he's amazingly I've
time to be strong and brave and capable
he'd be so proud you mean more than I
already am
oh but it's not real
ah Wow just look at you just look at you
but I told you to keep this short you
don't know how hard it is to find
scissors these days time to go clip in
time
you've got people that need you
goodbye Lee
[Music]
goddamn Clem wake up it's time to go
we got a long walk
I like how the little flap of the cap is
like falling off hey just notice that
finally a real moment very nice so it's
kind of moment you miss with these games
that's what makes them worthwhile in my
opinion damn that was unnecessary hey
you can just throw a rock you're neither
waste ah ah ah oh my gosh I'm dying
she's gonna go disguise I guess we're
really doing this only the team blending
in with the walkers need to cover
themselves now I just need your walker
friend is here good lord
yeah hello actually match day very nice
to meet you guys
this is James he's my friend no you
don't have any friends aging he's so
cool alright don't masturbate on
Clementine guys right on
that's not a good really quiet someone
might hear you loud is bed Thanks aging
wow your absolute brain late sorry I'll
be quiet
oh sorry I try to shoot at one time your
mask looks so real functional and
fashionable
I'll take too funny hahaha is this the
guy that Clem said she'd marry yeah I'm
quiet could I speak to you alone for a
moment good idea hold tight hey yeah 10
come here buddy I gotta tell you
something
the walkers they'll be here in a little
while you can join them as they pass
through the trees the noise from the
boat will draw them toward the water and
we can get on board and save our friends
your friends are different open-minded
accepting maybe one day you'll be the
same you know that sound is disgusting
Mass and Clementine I need to talk to
you about AJ he pooped in front of my
yard the whispers or my family from a
young age and that time I witnessed a
lot of death and suffering eventually I
became the cause of it
witness was considered a poison and I
believed in that fiercely so much so
that when another boy expressed sympathy
for our enemy before an attack
I slit his throat didn't consider who he
was I felt honestly I don't even
remember his name what you were like
James after he died I kept hearing his
words in my head those people are like
us just on a different path
I stopped killing after that I changed
no one else did when AJ told me he
killed someone it reminded me of them
of myself he said it was wrong but it
sounded like he was just repeating what
he'd been told taking life like that
from a young age it breaks something
inside you
I just I'm afraid if AJ kills again he
won't be able to go back to showing the
Gillette commercial boy he was babbled
fix a I've seen it happen too many times
I'm not going to let AJ become a killer
I don't want him to change not like that
I hope you can keep that promise they're
close assume there will be enough of
them to provide us cover blow up the
boat I'll lead you through the herd
until you reach the boat blow up the
boat Samar cycle after that it's up to
you let's just blow up the boat let's
just blow up the boat guys like what do
you guys want to do take care of AJ okay
he's ready to go AJ give me the gun the
walkers are getting close Ruby you're in
charge of the horses really dead take
care of the supplies and I'm in charge
of the bomb find the boiler there'll be
a door on the bottom with ash and stuff
put it in there
see you all on the other side okay not
on this zombie side I hope that would be
really bad
all right what do you want Lois told me
about me that Sophie died and Minnie is
one of them now
just did you see her out there
tell her tell her I forgive her please I
tell her myself but sure I just wanted
to be okay yeah all right sure you
thought wait sir if we see her I'll let
her know
Thanks bye
oh god I gotta talk to everyone about
their feelings before we go in there
feelings
[Music]
Clementine before we and there isn't it
before we go and do this thing that we
got to do I just first need to tells
lives are depending on us depending on
me you're depending on me to what do
something happens to you Clem what what
if I can't I don't know I can't carry
that the rest of my life you just have
to try you have to try Louis no matter
what you think about yourself
yeah if you don't go they all are mm-hmm
you can't fall apart right now no not
now I wish I could help it okay I'll try
cool
what if I just get us caught - all it
would take is one little screw-up and
I'd screw up all the time
that's not right come on Louis get it
together I need you to slap me help pull
me out of this right here
come on just give him a Louis you'll be
okay
I like that a lot more
it's ready okay
oh we're not doing what I think we are
that depends what do you think we're
doing
Oh God we are it'll help us blend in
with the walkers use guts okay so we
take it the guts and we rub it on their
clothes we could have changed clothes
before so we don't waste our outfits but
no that looks so gross here that's a
nice jacket too like it's so every way
you're not open up your mouth there you
know walk your blood is one of the
hardest things to get out you owe me
some new clothes you gonna do it
you're doing it
here we freakin gold charge attack
country roads take me home to the pace I
blow blow up roads and save the kids
take me home
boo boo okay
oh that was Jerry use them as shields
all right okay
it's hug time
tab at half that bad
Stevie Dee boo oh shoot dude he just
shot my new friend all right do you want
to be my friend hug time oh damn it
alright looks like we did it time
like I'm doing this wrong
Walker on Willie
I'll supplies it's really lagging what
in the world okay now's our chance
oh my god we can't risk leaving cover
we'll have to call along the side of the
dock
can they do such slam out anyway
like what's the zombie move really
necessary I guess so
the guts are coming off
well you know you live some you lose
some let's just get up here oh no that's
bad okay now let's go grouse shooter in
the penis
follow me this way I don't know if it's
me that's lagging or if it's due there
somebody's in the water this is like
Pirates of Caribbean that episode when
they like oh we're gonna walk and then
they walk it's really cool I don't know
if you have seen that but it's really
cool
go on bite I have this amazing PC oh hey
hey hey hey there's sharks the Frick is
your problem I'm not a wind chime okay
dude it's so laggy what happened you
okay I'm fine
I'm gonna should I restart I need to
wait for a checkpoint done what do I do
this is super annoying let me let me see
if I can restart my recording three two
one okay oh good okay here we go
gameplay this is to prove a once and for
all I'm a gay
ah
Jesus Christ the language in likes at
the same spots too so it must be the
game ready AJ PC master-race
it's more likely she craps speech state
all right and cool right in the bananas
holy [ __ ] it's lagging new I can't play
like this am I gonna use the arrow or
what
[Applause]
all right I need to do something this is
crazy
[Applause]
okay as soon as we go in here I'm gonna
restart there we go that's the same
perfect ever since I was a nun I've been
standing and sure okay man I remember
oh they got more hay and stuff dude
we're getting close after we find the
boiler and place the bomb we'll get our
friends out and he said there were eight
Raiders but we didn't see that many
outside all right this has been going on
for long enough and I haven't said
anything but they are stealing the pause
from beyond two souls okay they do the
exact same thing they go on the boat and
then they blow up the boat
am I just going to pretend that they're
not played your oh [ __ ] hey
conveniently-placed
nice cover very nice do none of us have
guns not a single gun uh I'm gonna go in
here check in here
you do that as well when you came under
a door yeah let's blow it up son okay
aah oh my god
hey it's banana man you ever heard of
the banana man eats your bananas ah this
guy likes his bananas
knock out or kill I think we'll go for a
knockout and then we'll take this cotton
and then we'll shoot him in the face
that was pretty badass not gonna lie
we're gonna blow up the boat so he's
gonna die anyway unless someone drags
him out that's where we need to plant
the ball there's too much stuff
they sure aren't wasting ammo all right
what's the plan
wait here shoot him in the ass it's
gonna die anyway I'm sorry baby let's
get I killed myself
no baby bye-bye
baby pie time to live up to your name
Ruby's revenge love and support you once
they start up this boat we won't have
much time before it explodes my phone
hello not sure an hour 30 minutes I
guess we'd better move
scuse me it worked my sister don't know
what she wants I'm sorry honey but I'll
talk to you later okay
sorry I missed what was happening
because reasons what am i doing I'll go
upstairs okay sure I can't believe I
just killed PewDiePie focus I have a
little brother he's short Scarface see
he's not out there is he no we've
discussed this
your family is Delta now they ain't no
room for anyone else yes ma'am
there's no way we can get in there
without her seeing us
I shoot her in the face put her in the
place yet out not without our people I
swear to God if you got ten caught up in
this just just tell me that he's safe
give me that he told me to tell you he
forgives you
[ __ ] I'll help you get everyone out then
you take my brother and run get him back
to where it's safe
you can come with this come on we have
to hurry [ __ ] oh my god are you okay
what's up homies I yeah I'm all right
we're all right get file it first she
needs to know you're here oh this guy
kid pilot first she needs to know we're
here we don't have a lot of time before
Dorian comes back blow up the boat just
blow up the boat Louis give me a hand
yeah sure violet exacta an attack so go
violet
[ __ ] dude oh [ __ ] Oh kill her AJ kill
her thanks for that violent things a lot
violet the Buddha's gonna blow up violet
hey it's me
thanks for coming back to me sorry Akeem
happy bye
are you okay talk to me
we're here to take you home I looked for
you when they grabbed me
I saw you let them take me I'm just
supposed to forget that because you're
here now some [ __ ] friend you are
whose wouldn't have stood a chance
against these guys I knew you could
fight back yeah sure what's wrong with
you bye come on yeah get the hell out of
here
no Clem I'm done this whole situation is
so [ __ ] at least you have Minnie you
mean the Minnie that betrayed us don't
act like you know her she tried to
escape her and Sophie they said if I
fight back they'd kill many or one of
you all you've done is get us hurt or
killed if you [ __ ] this up worse
I'll stop you myself and don't think I
won't I'm losing her again or anyone
else can't give up now
if they take us back to their community
we'll all die so what your plan is to
speed up the process
whatever you do leave me out of it okay
escape
alright that's look they have scratches
here that long
well we physically can't because looks
like there's a gap here those about my
hand through no that would have changed
everything
oh you all got caught Jesus Christ
are you alright I'm fine where's AJ
yes I am alright thank you for asking
his vaio right she's saying she won't
help us [ __ ] there's being a bit of a
sour face to be honest ah
we're not moving yet so at least we've
got some time I guess
what violet you must help me please
please smell of violets
combien coming and violet come in my way
she scares the [ __ ] out of me Clem
thanks guys talk [ __ ] I don't think I've
ever been that afraid she's not messing
around
yeah become soup just hang in there yes
you did you shoot there AJ yeah I'm all
right
I'm looking for a way out yeah he has
his little window very well made maybe
that's something we can work with
perhaps if we like spit on them and it's
acid so it Lewis are you alright
me yeah I'm fine just trying to figure
out the best way to survive an explosion
alright come on guys
if you work together we can solve
anything violet it's just where you pee
disgusting maybe we can use to pee in
acid all right
[Music]
that's note there all right we haven't
talked to Cole mana hurt get out are you
all ready yeah well thank you let's just
get a D what can I say except you're all
Mar I think that GPU is kicking in okay
Oh latch that freaking Lance Brown you
might be able to chip away in this if I
had a tool or Dan they must have taken
away my knife I want your coffee maker
you have your coffee maker in your back
pocket you still have your knife yeah
they didn't find it only the big one
good I need you to slide it over to me
nice where did where'd he go don't tell
me where that bap bap bap bap era better
better come on cut my ship with some
pieces let's get this [ __ ] door come
on come on just open
really don't chose I promise it ain't
worth it
standing out on the deck she awake yes
ma'am
slide the ship away uh-oh
that's not gonna be gay oh hey maggot
where's Abel he's dead we killed him we
put a knife in his head [ __ ] Jesus
little monster damn it
we showed him mercy he was terrified of
turning so we stopped him from having to
we gave him what he wanted
I'm sure you did
back up
Minerva open the door yes ma'am
normally the trouble you caused I'd
shoot you and toss you overboard but I'm
genuinely impressed first you organized
these idiot kids into a fighting force
and killed two of my most experienced
soldiers then you sneak onto my boat
under the cover of a herd I bring a
prize like you back to the Delta
it might make this whole [ __ ] of
a mission worth it someone like you so
yeah with so much potential look if I'm
the one you want let the others go
this isn't a negotiation this is me
telling you how things are going to be
you know my father Larry was a military
man
hey Larry that's not even a real name
all kinds of rules the thing that bugged
him most was waste if I ever left a
light on after leaving a room he'd flip
no matter how many times he ranted about
the cost of electricity I could never
remember to hit that switch Oh sounds
like you were a dumbass kid so one day
he let our power get cut
he liked illustrations to show that
actions have consequences Jesus Christ
she looks terrifying Omar hairdryer no
more ice cream sandwiches
I guess [ __ ] runs in the family is
that ice cream sandwiches thank you said
the consequence is I never left the
lights on again my father had his faults
but he showed me the effectiveness of
teaching by example oh is that what this
is a lesson
I want to tell you a story let's call it
the parable of the twins two girls were
taken from their home and brought to a
new place to live they had to leave
their friends and family behind and that
was hard at first
they shed a lot of tears but the new
place was a good place the people there
grew corn and raised pigs and the twins
ate well for the first time in years
they had hot showers clean clothes beds
they were given guns and trained to use
them the people there were kind to these
girls all that was asked in return was
that they helped defend the group you
see this place had a lot of enemies
killers and thieves who wanted what they
had they needed help fighting or they
lose everything they built their cross
oh my god how generous their lives being
to fight how generous they were just
doing what they needed to survive one of
the girls saw that this was a place
worth fighting for and her tears dried
but the other twin she could never
forget her old home she rejected every
gift every opportunity stirred up
trouble every chance she got she
convinced her sister to help her steal a
raft and leave on the river of course
they didn't get far what happened then
Minerva
[Music]
I killed her you're crazy what the [ __ ]
is that true your own sister why would
you do that
she was twisting my head with her life
and I made a mistake
I need it to show my loyalty to the
place I call home like it or not you're
one of my people now Clem the question
is which twin are you going to be the
loyal one
or the dead one back away from the door
I'll kill your Knisley
all right Lily you made your point I'll
do what you want don't say that Clem
look what they did to Minnie just don't
hurt anyone else
good I'm surprised to hear you Bend so
easily but as I said before this isn't a
negotiation
pull the mouthy one out of the cell it's
killing time he clearly didn't get the
moral of the story we'll have to help
them understand stop
don't hurt Lois or I'll hurt you oh [ __ ]
eggsy you better cool it oh you gonna
get yourself
easy ajj you deserve to die will kill
you you think you can kill me I know I
can well throw you in the river I will
put a knife right to the side of your
head
they talk for a little guy no I can do
it I killed Marlon
he wasn't Jesus his eyes oh my god
agents a badass dank
oh my god he is the smartest person on
the plane it was Marlon oh god she's
gonna take him she can turn him around I
bet you'd make a great soldier leave him
alone this is between us
clam seems to care a lot about you come
on let's go have a chat they did a good
job on her character at how it looks
like he really fits a villain keep an
eye on her Minerva I want to be far away
from you that I'll start up the boy
[Music]
honey don't you dare look at me like
that this is the only way we survive are
you serious right now after everything
that she's done you just better help her
[Music]
how can Minerva have the nerves yeah
violet your being is such a [ __ ]
spoiled little piece of [ __ ] honestly Oh
bazinga you just got put seeing it out
of nowhere
yeah behind you Clin ow all right so I'm
pressing Q like very fast just shoot her
she's gone Oh
[Music]
kill her kill them all
stab her in the butt no stab her in the
knees it was a Miss click it's okay it
happens we have to go we planted a bomb
on the boat [ __ ] you there's a bum mitch
is dead you just [ __ ] boat we have to
get the hell out of here now go I need
to find agent I I can't
fine better see you on land you will
good chicken
goichi game go chicken social being
grouchy game
don't you dare touch him Shh start the
boiler oh no that's really bad
once the boiler gets hot enough the hole
will poke just gonna go shopping kept
him I've known Clementine since before
this all started choking you'll come
around too once you see what we have to
offer plenty of food comfortable beds
for you in hope you'll didn't show you
once you see what we have to offer
plenty you just have to stuff for the
ones Tim don't know they happen
Tennessee did you get lost
ma'am he wasn't alone I got something
else to show
this way
found this you know hurt
oh no they got the hammer somewhere done
must have thought you were clever
leading those waters here nothing today
you don't [ __ ] scary
is that so force your ways onto others
because you're afraid because you're
waiting I get my people across to fight
for the thing about people like him
aging is that they're too broken to fit
into a community they won't buy for
anyone but themselves
that's not true he fought for us and he
has really big eyebrows shoot him shoot
him 10 don't shoot him hey Jay
I'm liking AJ more and more shoot her
[ __ ] here [ __ ] her and then you shoot
her and then you're good to go
[Music]
Oh God
although Kenny - hey Jay grab the gun AJ
AJ wake up AJ AJ would be the best
Walker in the game yeah me oh god you're
so ugly
ow
spider it shift e attack yeah now shoot
her shoot
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh right it's Ella
aging aging-- me why is it not working
than the attacks on it's a lot of blood
man AJ man it's AJ time
gerrate her and she's not a threat
Martha card you walk down you didn't see
what she did
you don't have to do this Lane it's a
trick
okay narrating
shoes are in the knee give me the kind
yeah anyone else
lower the gun eg
I know it's lame but they already warned
about it and I don't want him to turn
into an [ __ ] even though I
desperately wanted her to shoot him or
the opposite of what I said but if it's
the wrong choice I'm going back because
I'm annoyed at bad
[Music]
at this guy serious did he just turn his
back against a woman that has a knife
this is happening when you cut that in a
video game okay AJ she's not a threat
she's not a threat
she's not a threat babies do
knocking there 18
just
to me the gun anyone else do it
AJ yeah no yeah yeah yes
hey J hey J ooh ooh
[Music]
Lily we couldn't find the other what did
you do
whoopsie [ __ ] dead whoopsie Oh
that'll be the boiler
okay what's going to happen next
that was a ok that was it
[Music]
what's up bro how's it going 7% of play
a force able to turn into a walker so
very few and three pretty really tough
choices this time around you and 93% of
players respect that James and kill no
walkers
12% of players named the bomb Berube's
revenge yeah it was a dumb name honestly
82% of players allowed AG to attack
Dorian stopping her from cutting okay
all right the last one is pretty good
350 percent yeah I don't care all right
things that don't matter
Lily dad
you
well I really did a lot of exploring
tonight okay oh man that was an epic
game we did it one more episode coming
up 26 of March